the talk of the town yesterday was Jimmy
Kimmel late night and he was telling a
story about his son is a newborn son who
tragically has a heart condition and he
was brought to Children's Hospital he
had to have emergency heart surgery
guess who's born maybe at Children's
Hospital or at least they transferred
him over there and human Kimmel told the
story and then he turns into a pitch for
Obamacare and I want to talk about this
because I have some personal thoughts on
the matter a little over a week ago on
Friday April 21st my wife Molly gave
birth to a boy baby boy and he appeared
to be a normal healthy baby until about
three hours after he was born when a
very attentive nurse at cedars-sinai
hospital
her name is nunu she was checking him
out and heard a murmur in his heart
which is common with newborn babies but
she also noticed he was a bit purple
they did an x-ray and his lungs were
fine which meant his heart wasn't so now
more doctors and nurses and equipment
come in and it's it's a terrifying thing
I'm up you know my wife is back in the
recovery room she has no idea what's
going on and I'm standing in the middle
of a lot of very worried looking people
kind of like right now we were trying to
figure out what the problem is
it's Friday night and so they call a
pediatric cardiologist dr. Evans on they
did an echocardiogram which is a
sonogram of the heart and found that
Billy was born with a heart disease
something called tetralogy of the low
with pulmonary atresia it's hard to
explain basically the pulmonary valve
was completely blocked and he has a hole
in the wall between the left and right
sides of his heart and then they brought
my wife in and they wheeled her in and
doctors on told her what was going on
what our options were we decided to take
him to Children's Hospital where there's
a world-renowned cardiac surgeon who is
by all accounts a genius his name is dr.
von Starnes so we put the baby in an
ambulance the Children's Hospital Los
Angeles and on Monday morning dr.
Starnes opened his chest and fixed one
of the two defects of his heart
it went in there with a scalpel and did
some kind of magic that I couldn't even
begin to explain he opened the valve and
the operation was a success it was the
longest three hours of my life and I
have a list of people I want to thank
for making that happen and I hope I have
my list these are just some of the
people he who played a part in this it
was an enormous team effort really was
at and I want to see one other thing
President Trump last month proposed a
six billion dollar cut in funding to the
National Institute of Health and thank
God our congressmen made a deal last
night to not go along with that they
actually increased funding by two
billion dollars none of the people who
have been affected by those cuts of the
Nationals do to help our children and it
would have a major impact on a lot of
great places including Children's
Hospital Los Angeles which is so
unbelievably sad to me we were brought
up to believe that we live in the
greatest country in the world but until
a few years ago millions of millions of
us had no access to health insurance at
all
you know before 2014 if you were born
with congenital heart disease like my
son was there was a good chance you'd
never be able to get health insurance
because he had a pre-existing condition
you were born with a pre-existing
condition if your parents didn't have
medical insurance you might not live
long enough to even get denied because
of a pre-existing condition if your baby
is going to die and it doesn't have to
it shouldn't matter how much money you
make I think that's something now
whether you're a Republican or Democrat
or something else we all agree on that
right on me okay so I have some
experiences here now to talk about them
and I don't really talk about this a lot
because I don't like to make my family
life an issue on the show and in
politics generally okay a couple of
years ago this have been mid of 2015 my
daughter was born in January 2014 mid
2015 like July 2015 my daughter who is a
beautiful little girl she is she is she
has the flu and she starts throwing up
and when she's throwing up she same
thing and we don't know why and so we
take her into that very scary room and
she's like Keeling over literally
fainting dead away while she's throwing
up
and it turns out that it was breath-hold
and we didn't know that so we go to the
ER and they do a bunch of tests on her
and one of the tests they do is they run
in EKGs on her and they say the EKG
looks basically normal but we just want
have some follow-up send us to a
cardiologist and the cardiologist takes
a second look and does an ultrasound
then tells us that she has a heart
murmur not just a heart murmur aha she
has it's actually such a large hole in
Harsha in the atrial septal defect nasty
and she had a heart murmur that was so
you can even hear it because the hole in
her heart was so large that you couldn't
actually normally the heart murmur comes
from you hear the the blood flowing the
wrong way through the heart you couldn't
hear it because the hole is so large in
her heart so in August of last year she
had to or August of 2015 rather she had
to have open-heart surgery the surgeon
was dr. Vaughn Starnes exactly the same
surgeon who worked on Jimmy Kimmel's kid
it was at Children's Hospital of Los
Angeles could not be more grateful to
Children's Hospital LA or dr. Starnes
who is indeed the master of his craft
there's a reason he's the best in the
world and we were lucky enough to be
able to to work with him and he
obviously did the work and saved our
daughter's life I mean she she wouldn't
have died immediately it wasn't like an
emergency situation quite as much as
Jimmy Kimmel skated sounds like but she
would have had failure to thrive as she
got older she would have had to have
open-heart surgery if they hadn't
detected it would have shorter life span
too you know 30 or 40 now they fixed it
she's good as new
thank God everything is fine and she's
great the reason that I tell this story
is because when Jimmy Kimmel starts
talking about the National Institutes
for health and federal funding and
health insurance and all the rest of us
the reason that I was able to get great
coverage for my kid is because I was
employed and also because my wife and I
had health insurance long before we had
a kid he's missing a couple of key
points here and I wanted to establish
sort of the bonafide he's here so I'm
speaking about I'm not speaking from the
perspective of someone who hasn't
experienced nearly identically what
Jimmy Kimmel has experienced here it was
absolutely terrifying when you go and
you meet with the doctor and the doctor
tells you your kid you know even if the
doctor says it's a surgery that's done
regularly it's still frightening is all
held because they're cracking open your
kid's chest and cutting or open and and
you know it was in hooking up the tubes
it was really terrifying and horrifying
and thank god she's okay but the point
is that when he immediately connects
that to federal funding when he commedia
connected to Obamacare I don't like the
process as a general rule I don't like
the process of using
personal stories like this to push for
legislation or to push for public policy
because it doesn't necessarily follow
and what I mean by this is again dr.
Starnes great dr. children hospital
grade hospital most of the people when
we were in Children's Hospital during
the recovery we were in the ICU for
about a week when we were in Children's
Hospital most of the people who are in
Children's House well I know this
because my wife rotated through
Children's Hospital because she's a
doctor in the LA area a huge number of
the kids in Children's Hospital are not
kids who have great insurance many of
them don't have any insurance the fact
is that in the United States of America
if you have an emergency situation like
Jimmy Kimmel had let's just assume this
happened at cedars-sinai again where my
wife gave birth let's assume that the
exact in situation happened but there
was no insurance and the doctor spotted
that there was this emergency surgery
that had to happen in order prolong the
child's life they don't ask insurance
they immediately send the kid over to
Children's Hospital and dr. Starnes
works on the kid because and then
somebody else fills the gap Children's
Hospital is very lucky and the
Children's has enormous sums of giving
people give tons of money to Children's
Hospital I'm sure Jimmy Kimmel will too
we giving charity to Children's Hospital
people there's a whole wall an entire
wall in Children's Hospital that is just
names of celebrities who have given
money to Children's Hospital to help
support Children's Hospital people are
generous what they're giving people want
to save people who are in need the
problem with the argument that we have
to cover pre-existing conditions which
is basically what Jimmy Kimmel saying
here's number one when it comes to
children it is the job of the parents to
have health insurance when the kid is
born because the parents health
insurance covers the kid right the fact
is that my kid was not buying her own
health insurance when she was a year and
a half old we had health insurance it
covered her that doesn't mean that if
there's a gap that we as a community
shouldn't step in that's with charities
for that's why hospitals cover the gap
that's why costs are passed on very
often throwback to our method via the
hospital to people who do have insurance
but it does say that it is a mistake as
a society to simply say to people that
there is no moral responsibility to get
health insurance well you're healthy
well you don't have health problems
because if you don't do that if there if
you just say whenever you get sick you
can immediately take advantage of the
system people will wait to get sick to
take advantage of the system and you
will end up bankrupting set of the
system the reason the children's is so
great is because children get paid lots
of money they paid lots and lots and
lots of money to do these sorts of
things dr. Starnes I'm sure millions of
dollars a year and he deserves
every penny that he makes and he's able
to do that because there are people
paying voluntarily into health insurance
to cover themselves so when something
bad happens he gets paid dr. Starnes is
not somebody who should be working for
60 grand you're like a postal worker if
you do that to the health system you're
not going to be able to get the kinds of
surgeries that dr. Starnes provides or
the kind of care that Children's
Hospital provides and I think it's
deeply important that when we talk about
everybody getting the sort of care that
Jimmy Kimmel's kid got or that my kid
gets in order for that to happen you
have to make it affordable and quality
the only thing that does that is a free
market and again that doesn't mean there
shouldn't be a safety net provided by a
society I'm not talking about through
government now I'm talking about through
charity and through communities and
through charity hospitals all of that is
true but to use a personal situation
that is really difficult and
heartbreaking in order to promulgate a
public policy that actually doesn't
achieve what you're seeking to achieve
children is not worthwhile Children's
Hospital could not be what Children's
Hospital is if it existed is a public
sector hospital unless you are willing
to tax people up the wazoo and that sort
of taxation scheme bankrupts countries
and doesn't provide the same care anyway
look at the National Health Service in
Britain or the or the nationalized
health care service in Canada this is
the I have nothing but sympathy for
Jimmy Kimmel because I've been through
as I say exactly the same thing and it's
heartbreaking and that heartbreak should
not be used as a political tool in order
to push a political agenda and I'm sure
that Jimmy Kimmel believes have reward
that he's saying but funding for the
National Institutes of Health has
nothing to do with what happened here
again the American people are insanely
generous the amount of research that
goes into the sorts of techniques that
dr. Starnes used is tremendous and it's
not from the public sector and most in
the most part it's actually from the
private sector